thouars patouillard bonsoir vous êtes de
militantes d'act up depuis 1994 et
présidente depuis 2001 mais comme c'est
une activité évidemment qui ne vous
rapporte pas d'argent bénévoles
donc vous êtes prof dans un lycée alors
avant d'entamer la discussion jeudi que
vous nous disiez quels sont les
objectifs d'act up
act up c'est une association de
personnes séropositives donc le but de
l'association c'est de lutter contre le
sida et de lutter aussi contre eux tout
ce qui contribue à la propagation
d'épidémies
d'accord alors acteur pas intervient à
travers ce que vous appelez entre vous
des dés à pain c'est à dire des
interventions médiatiques pour vous
faire remarquer il ya eu ici sur ce
plateau il ya quinze jours 1 ap
parce que j'avais reçu plusieurs fois
d'ailleurs c'est vrai denrées droite
rive gauche d'attribuer sur ce plateau
un garçon qui s'appelle érik rémès et on
va voir de quoi il s'agit manitoba
d'isère ce dont tu connais
avec ray mais ce qu'est ce qu'un berbère
coeur alors barbe à coeur c'est une
personne séropositive qui désirent avoir
des rapports sexuels non protégés avec
d'autres barback heures avec d'autres
personnes séropositives
il ya aussi une forme plus radicale qui
est le bar bakker qui veut contaminer
les personnes séronégatives voilà et ben
moi j'ai voulu un petit peu traitée tout
ce problème là par exemple quand vous
dites alors vous pouvez dire que c'est
le personnage du roman et que sais pas
vous mais quand vous infecter sciemment
un garçon qui s'appelle pierre sous
prétexte qu'il est con et prétentieux et
que vous rajouter c'est un service à lui
rendre
pour donner un sens à sa vie c'est quand
même excuse moi c'est un crime de
détraqués il ya pas y'a pas d'autres
morts ça c'est pas jouer les moralistes
mais c'est un crime c'est un roman oui
il ya marqué roman quand il ya marqué
roman est tout à fait donc je dis pas
que j'ai fait j'ai pratiqué ces choses
là j'ai même façon il ya beaucoup de
gens éventuellement que j'aurais
contaminée qui auraient été contaminés
ailleurs de toute façon à taratata
ratant sa passe
m
il a opéré
sachez qu apparaît dès que je vais y
aller
[Applaudissements]
à
et bien ça y est tu monde est calme et
pour une fois ça vous concerne pas mon
cher klugman
c'était act up voilà donc ça c'était sur
le plateau de tout le monde en parle il
y a quinze jours
effectivement sur le moment j'ai compris
que c'était act up mais j'avais pas du
tout réalisé que c'était en liaison avec
l'invitation de érik rémès dont qui sait
pas qui soutient mais enfin qui fait la
propagande du barebacking si vous aviez
voulu le savoir vous pouviez vous
demandé j'aurais pu vous le dire mais
moi j'aime moi justement j'aime pas
qu'on débarque sur mon plateau sans me
prévenir pourquoi alors je vous pose la
question très simplement et victoire
pourquoi ne pas m'avoir rappelé trois
jours avant dix ans écoutait ardisson
vous invitez rémès nous ça nous plaît
pas du tout on veut pouvoir venir le
dire sur votre plateau que vous savez
bien qu'ici on reçoit des gens qui ont
des avis extrêmement différent vous
savez bien reçoit goupil en reçoit de la
baie et dieudonné
alors pourquoi ne pas m'avoir appelé
avant je crois que les gens ont compris
avec l'extrait que vous avez passé le
bareback c'est donc un discours qui fait
l'apologie des pratiques à risque et qui
appelle à la contamination
c'est ça le bareback donc évidemment
nous en tant qu association de lutte
contre le sida lutter contre le bareback
c'est un de nos objectifs
à partir de ce moment là effectivement
on fait tout pour que ce discours soit
le moins diffusés possible avant que ms
soit invitée dans l'émission tribu on a
eu toute la production de votre émission
leur a demandé de ne pas inviter ses
vrais écrivains barebackers et vous les
avez invité tout à fait donc là ce qu'on
veut nous c'est pas c'est pas passé à la
télé c'est pas ça notre objectif parce
que ça va pas annuler une fois que érik
rémès a été invité une fois qu'il a pu
effectivement vendre son livre les faits
et là est la question qu on veut enfin
le problème qu'on veut poser ses
problèmes de votre responsabilité à vous
parce que c'est vous qui choisissez
autorités c'est vous qui choisissez
ce type de discours vous savez les
conséquences et vous savez que ça va
avoir des conséquences en matière de
contamination donc à partir de ce moment
là la question c'est la question votre
responsabilité
mais je vais vous répondre mais moi je
trouve que dans cette émission on montre
des choses qui existent même si on n'est
pas toujours d'accord avec ces choses et
je pense que montrer des gens qui
pratiquent le barebacking c'est à dire
des séropositifs qui baisent sans capote
pour être clair je pense que le fait de
dire que ça existe ça une fonction
prophylactique
c'est à dire que ça dit aux gens mettez
la capote encore plus qu'avant parce que
maintenant il ya des cinglés voudrais
bien mais j'ai dit détraqué il ya des
cinglés des détraqués qui baisent sans
capote donc les mecs c'est comme ça donc
moi le fait de le montrer je suis je
vous dis franchement je cherche pas à me
disculper
je dis franchement le fait de montrer
des becker pour moi c'est une façon de
dire méfiez-vous encore plus voilà et
vous vous dites c'est votre avis je le
respecte
vous dites non il faut pas les montrer
du tout voilà ce que je vous dis c'est
que voulait montrer systématiquement
c'est à dire que guillaume dustan qu'est
un autre écrivain baker vous l'avait
invité à chaque fois qu'il a sorti un
livre éric n'avait pas besoin d'appeler
aussi simplement il a dit sur votre
plateau meurt plus du sida ce qui est un
mensonge évidemment personne ne l'a
repris donc à ce moment là effectivement
érik rémès sort un livre personne n'en
parle dans la presse mais vous vous
l'invitez toutefois savez pourquoi
parfois on les voit les livres dont on
parle pas c'est cela dont je veux parler
c'est pour ça que ma blessure ce plateau
ce soir c'est pour ça que plein de gens
sa venue sur ce je pense que la
démocratie c'est que tout le monde
puisse parler mais seulement il ya
plusieurs manières effectivement de
faire état du bareback et le livre des
récrés mais s'il s'agit pas c'est pas un
reportage s'est pas présenté un état des
lieux dire ça le bareback voilà ça
existe non c'est appeler à la
contamination notamment à la
contamination des militants d'act up
paris par exemple et c'est faire la
promotion des pratiques arrive est ce
que vous avez lu ce livre
oui alors je peux vous lire un passage
vous me dites simplement ce que vous en
pensez d'accord alors pour plomber
quelqu'un je précise plombé ça veut dire
contaminée pour tomber quelqu'un c'est
également très simple il suffit d'un peu
de doigté de patience et de subterfuges
on retire discrètement la capote pendant
la belle on fait semblant de la m les
plombs burke rêve préalablement les
capotes avec une aiguille d'autres les
sortes de l'emballage et des couples
réservoir il la remette ensuite
ensuite on à la description très lente
et très avec beaucoup de plaisir de la
contamination d'un militant d'act up qui
se termine pas j'ai pompé une acte png
plomber une acte piennes tralalala la
tra la la la la
dès le lendemain la fit la mode a été
vite répandue qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
j'en pense exactement ce que je vous ai
dit c'est à dire que ça existe
apparemment les gens que j'avais parlé
avec les messes de cette idée de couper
le bout de la capote pour que le sperme
puisse passer évidemment et je trouve
que le faire je suis complètement court
mais je trouve que le fait de dire que
ça existe ça doit inciter les gens à
mieux porter la capote voilà je suis
désolé c'est ma conviction je peux pas
vous dire le contraire mais vous
diffusez vous diffusez ce discours dont
vous refusez en vérité d'avoir votre
responsabilité c'est saint laurent vous
de ma responsabilité elle et de dire aux
téléspectateurs
faites gaffe il ya des cinglés qui coupe
le bout des capotes pour filmer le sida
d'autres gens je encore de moussa
n'avait pas nous ne savait pas donc nous
l'a découvert par votre émission ce qui
a été je pense un bon vecteur aussi pour
vous parce que le problème ça permet de
faire une
une sorte de communication aussi pour
votre association
mais notre but sensibiliser démarche
complètement différente non je ne crois
pas qu invité un écrivain qui fait
l'apologie des pratiques à risque ouais
ça soit une bonne chose pour la lutte
contre le sida garde les gens c'est ça
la touche je pense qu'effectivement il
faut de la prévention et explique
effectivement mais vous allez être
émotionnel mois que la prévention ça je
crois que la prévention efficace je peux
pas dire autre chose je crois
effectivement que la particularité de
l'épidémie de sida c'est que c'est nous
une épidémie qui se diffuse par des
pratiques et d'information allée
centrale ce qui est central c'est
diffuser la bonne information walad
invité des écrivains leur buteur comme
le fait thierry ardisson absolument
systématiquement le problème par
ailleurs c'est que c'est une émission de
service public c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui la seule manière de parler
du sida effectivement c'est d'inviter
des écrivains verbeek à ce moment là
effectivement c'est un jeu de service
public à avoir là dedans parce que si
sous prétexte qu'on travaille dans le
service public on doit faire des
émissions consensuel c'est plus le
service mais qui est intéressant dans
service public pardon mais ce que tu as
fait un seul public enfin à mon sens
c'est france inter par rapport à rtl
c'est france 2 par rapport à tf1 sur
cette liberté qu'on a d'inviter des gens
comme dieudonné comme d'hab qui sont pas
politiquement correct je pense qu'à une
époque personne voulait inviter dieudo
iliaque ici qu'ils pouvaient par les
nappes c'est pareil je pense que ms je
trouve ça dégueulasse je lui dit qu'il
était un détraqué mais le fait de dire
il ya des cinglés qui baise des séropos
qui baisent sans capote je pense que
c'est une démarche prophylactique voit
donc notre jeu je vous demande est
d'accord avec moi je dis simplement que
je ne vous méprenez pas je n'ai aucune
envie aucune envie de propager le sida
rassurez vous et je pense qu'elle fait
je pense que si un petit scandale dans
votre émission a pour conséquence des
contaminations et ensuite des cadavres
mais que ça vous fait gagner quelques
points d'audimat ce n'est pas un
problème je vous laisse la
responsabilité des acteurs
cette émission fait 30% de parts de
marché régulièrement depuis des années
elle n'a pas besoin de scandale pour
continuer à réussir voilà c'est parce
que la valeur que ça que ça mais les
gens aujourd'hui ont besoin d'être
choqués pour comprendre de plus en plus
malheureusement
malheureusement quand guillaume dustan a
dit sur votre plateau plateau on ne
meurt plus du sida personne ne la
contredit vous vous rendrez compte la
portée de tels propos
aujourd'hui où on sait que l'épidémie de
sida par ailleurs elle est en pleine
reprise
on sait qu'il ya toujours pas de
prévention à l'école et vous laisser ses
propos justement là il ya un rôle de
service public effectivement je crois
que la prévention ça fait partie des
missions de service public je vous ai
dit ce que j'en pensais vous dites ce
que vous en pensez
clairement les yeux dans les yeux
maintenant parlons cinq minutes d'act up
c'est à dire il ya le livre
effectivement dairy crest metz il ya le
livre d'alain soral aussi auquel vous
vous en prenez et alors là je voudrais
qu'on s'explique aussi vous avez saccagé
c'est-à-dire qu'act up est allé saccagé
les bureaux d'un éditeur qui s'appelle
les éditions blanches qui sont dirigés
par franck cela comme vous voulez on
appelait des affiches sur les murs d'une
sonde ai dit si vous avez vite de tous
et l'assistant pièce d'identité sur une
surprise un petit peu parce que non mais
la visite une assistante a été blessée
elle a voulu empêcher à une pile de
livres de tomber effectivement elle a
pris un livre cheval a quand même été
arrêté six jours mais les actions d'act
up
pour ceux qui ont pu en voir sont les
actions absolument non violente c'est à
dire qu'on s'en prend pas aux personnes
mais moi j'ai quelques jours j'ai vu
arriver sur ce plateau c'était
franchement violent avec les vigiles ça
a été extrêmement violent et j'en suis
vraiment j'en suis désolé parce que
c'est nous qui avons plutôt j'ai mis les
coûts mais on est une association non
violence la violence qu'on utilise c'est
une violence symbolique effectivement
coller des affiches dans une maison
d'édition prendre des livres sur des
rayonnages et les jeter par terre c'est
une violence symbolique mais c'est rien
par rapport à la violence qui a exercé
par ses propres de deuxième action d'act
up vous avez saccagé le journal 20 ans
non c'est pareil on a collé des affiches
parce que alain soral il travaille donc
c'est dire aux gens qu'ils emploient
alain soral si vous continuez à employer
alain soral on viendra
kg vos bureaux jusqu'à ce que vous
l'employez plus donc c'est une façon la
façon de le mettre au chômage avaient
été mal informé le journal 20 ans a été
happé parce que il y avait un article
qui donnait toutes les raisons de ne pas
coucher avec quelqu'un et parmi ces
raisons il y avait le fait qu'ils soient
séropositifs
est ce que quelqu'un a quelque chose à
dire dieudo zazie c'est difficile
d'avoir un point de vue parce que c'est
vrai aussi que moi j'ai été abandonné
zapper à tort et je suis et je suis ici
j'ai été j'ai eu et j'ai une tribune
pour pouvoir m'exprimer et puis
expliquer mon problème donc je pense que
c'est aussi la chance d'avoir ici un
endroit où tout le monde peut venir
s'exprimer c'est toujours délicat quand
même pas attendre et qui ne peut pas
venir s'exprimer
dites moi tant la victoire vont
sérieusement
dites moi à part des néonazis des mecs
d'extrême droite des fascistes que je ne
recevrai jamais c'est parce que je
soutiens
dites moi qui je n'invite pas sur ce
plateau sérieusement dites moi quel est
le le courant de pensée qui ne sont pas
invités s'ils disent pas c'est à dire en
matière de lutte contre le sida à part
les berbères coeur depuis un an qui avez
vous invité c'est vrai il faut savoir
une chose c'est que déjà il lutte contre
contre un espèce de consensus et atroce
qui concerne on attend c'est que le sida
n'existe plus et qu'on rattrape plus ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que c'est souvent des gens
qui sont séropositifs
au mieux c'est à dire qu'ils sont
confrontés au réel de la maladie et que
je pense que mon et la confronter à tout
ce qui a de différence entre le réel et
une observation de la réalité qui est la
télévision je comprends le point de vue
de thierry ardisson
je pense que en effet malheureusement
pour la plupart des gens qui regardent
la télévision c'est plus parlant de voir
l'aberration de ce genre de pratique que
parfois les actes de déjean d'act up
je suis la première à trouver ça
absolument atroce on est dans un espèce
de consensus d'assaut sur total qui va
vous
mais tant mieux si je veux dire acteur
peut être là aussi pour dire attention
combat n'est pas dans une témoin nuage
de la réalité mais dans un rayon les
gens comme rem est ce justement
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait parce que pour
moi c'est des criminels
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait est ce qu'ils
vont en prison est ce que parce qu'ils
sont là à visage ouvert il vit ça comme
s'il était une banalité mais c'est quand
même une démence total ces deux là c'est
du domaine du démontage et des lacs et
des agrumes de détraqués c'est un cri
mais seulement pour ce métier écrit
celui qui diffuse le discours c'est à
dire l'éditeur ou vous n'a aucune
responsabilité et c'est ça qui m'étonne
dans votre discours vous ne voulez
porter aucune responsabilité sur
l'attention alors que sans vous le
bareback n'existerait pas c'est à dire
que médiatiquement c'est vous qui avez
donné une audience vervaeke
on les invite en 6 tc vous savez c'est
comme si vous disiez vous parlez des néo
nazis parce que c'est pas bien
las il faut dire qu'à des mais honnête
écoutez moi je vais vous dire une chose
que peu après après j'aurais posé une
question soit moi je veux dire une chose
ya deux théories dans la vie il n'ya pas
de liberté pour les ennemis de la
liberté et ja je ne partage pas vos
idées mais je suis prêt à mourir pour
que vous puissiez les exprimer
moi je suis de la seconde catégorie
voilà je vais pas ajouter quelque chose
je vous en prie a raison
je ne veux pas profiter de mon statut
d'animateur je discute avec vous la
liberté d'expression c'est pas je dis
quelque chose et ensuite je m'en lave
les mains donc la liberté évidemment la
liberté d'expression a stoppé pour mais
aussi la responsabilité de ses actes et
la responsabilité de ce que m'ont dit
voilà moi je vous dis que pour moi
lutter contre la propagation du sida ça
passe aussi par le fait de montrer des
berbères coeur vous me dites non je vous
dis oui je pense qu'on a pas d'accord en
refusant des messages de prévention sur
la réalité d'entraînement on va terminer
là dessus je voulais vous demander une
simple chose à l'époque où act up lutter
par exemple pour que les préservatifs
soient vendus moins chers pour qu'on
retrouve des préservatifs partout moi
j'étais un très grand partisan d'act up
ce que je comprends moins aujourd'hui
dans l'attitude d'acteurs permettez moi
de vous le dire victoire que vous êtes
la présidente c'est quelle est votre
légitimité pour donner des leçons de
morale c'est à dire qu'est ce qui vous
donne ou parlez vous calé qui êtes vous
pour nous dire ce qu'on doit faire et à
faire est ce que le fait d'être
homosexuel donne un droit non ça
n'enlève pas des droits mais ça n'en
donne pas non plus alors notre
légitimité c'est que on est comme gelée
dit une association de malades on est
une association effectivement issu de la
communauté homosexuelle
on travaille maintenant depuis plus de
dix ans et je pense effectivement qu'on
a une légitimité sur la question du sida
pour et sur la question aussi de l'image
et des représentations parce qu'il faut
voir aussi le discours de la honte dont
on est sortis act up a contribué à
donner une visibilité aux malades a
donné aussi une image positive et c'est
pour ça que la question de l'image la
question des représentations on donne du
sida est une question qui est importante
et je pense c'est pas des leçons de
morale mais c'est des questions
effectivement qui sont des questions
politiques si vous voulez mais de
politique d'urgence vitale prend
d'accord en tout cas moi je suis je
voudrais dire c'est que aujourd'hui tous
les deux vous ne vous avez convaincu que
c'était une guerre utile le se battent
contre ce genre de torchon cucquois ces
six mois je vais dénoncer mais pour des
lancers
invité l'histoire je vous aviez à dire
oui je souhaiterais que vous cessiez
d'inviter des écrivains vers baker
d'accord et je compte je crois que le
bareback s'arrêtera au moment où vous
vous arrêterez les enjeux responsable du
bareback en france non mais de sa
diffusion wii de son importance et sa
diffusion il pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous